in our series on the new normal the
world from home we want to bring the
world to you since travel is limited
this summer this morning we show you how
an historic flour mill in southern
England came out of retirement to help a
community stuck indoors when coronavirus
lockdown started baking bread at home
became a hugely popular activity leading
to flour shortages Ian Lee takes us
inside the mill to see how it cranked up
production
good morning only in England can you
find a thousand-year-old flour mill now
around here as the lockdown hit and
businesses closed the only thing that
didn't grind to a halt was this place
time flows slowly at stern Minster
Newton mill
water from the River Stour has been
driving machinery here from as far back
as 1016 heavy stones grinding wheat into
flour
century after century demand wasn't what
it used to be until now says had Miller
Peter loose more people running out of
flour so you kind of saw your calling a
bit yes I suppose so
lockdown came along we had already set
up the mill ready for our usual season
which is just for occasional visitors
really within probably about 10 days to
a fortnight we realized that all the
local shops were running out of flour
the mill largely a tourist attraction in
recent years doubled the amount of flour
it usually produces during an entire
summer in just a few weeks it suddenly
threw the clock right back to medieval
times almost working the mill just as it
used to who for the local population
really knights in shining armor were
roaming these fields when this mill was
founded it survived Wars mad monarchs
and of course plagues and pandemics add
to that list the coronavirus lockdown so
how important is the mill today ask a
local shopkeeper Wow
Loy Mays made a massive difference door
manager Adam Vincent says folks drive
for hours around to get their hands on
this white gold dust we went with some
really really big wholesalers and it's
been so hard to get hold of it is
virtually impossible we've not seen
demand for flour and yeast like this
ever this is different different level
they do the flower shortage also hit
nearby Baker Stephen Oxford we nearly
ran out of flour and this funny old mill
down the road that can only produce a
few sacks a day at most stepped up came
in which means he could continue to
produce the most ancient of comfort
foods what is it that makes people reach
for bread in times of crises
Comfort getting a product and something
truly homemade and home-baked there is a
as soon as is that when times are hard
people eat white bread and and that's
because it's a very traditional thing to
do so it's a comfort food it's the
original comfort food isn't it original
food make in the most original of ways
the flour production here really has
been phenomenal but speaking to the
Miller he tells me once the pandemic is
over he's looking forward to things
going back to a slower pace for CBS this
morning
Ian Lee in Dorset England it really is
the original comfort food you know I
think it's so funny that in this country
we're running out of toilet paper there
they were running out of flour what does
that say about us I also and that I love
it when you actually hear Brits say
blimey in the story yeah I actually
believe they say that materially they do